test test
okay it's working I'm proper waltzes who
you may know from the view in 2020 but
now I have a new view from your screen
tablets and laptops joining me today is
Gwyneth Paltrow
if the interwebs is where the cool kids
hang while then man troduce you the
coolest girl in the world
I call it gee pal you may not yeah
please don't call me Jean pally they're
only cam Diaz does that
it's all right Barba selfie time oh that
looks great - Lauren babes barber that's
a picture of your thumb let's do that
again
arthritis yeah I hear that questions are
asked these days on the Twitter so I'm
going to read you some of the questions
girls that's kind of hot
these are very crude do you know what
people are saying about you on the
interwebs let me tell you Barb's I do
know it's like fighting my own war from
my mansion in Brentwood but at least I
have a pool can I go swimming sometime
only if you have a vegan bathing suit I
do not guess I'll have to swim in the
nude don't be some saggy titties in your
pool it'll be like a floating device for
apple and Moses vegetarian 11 asks I
want to goop tattoo any suggestions you
know it's a great question Barbara if I
had to choose one quote to ink on my
Pilates town body I'd probably choose
I'd rather smell crack than eat cheese
from a tin god I can picture it now it's
time for a Barbara question if you were
an emoji what emoji would you be
is there a kale emoji of course there's
not because the only thing better than
kale is kale Carol it makes me barf
they cry I'm sorry did I hurt cows
feelings just keep going
check out these graphics Gweneth you are
an award-winning actress a mother what I
think you're best at is quit of selfies
what is your secret cuz Fox wants to
know well it's very simple actually and
you have to just have a clean living a
$500 an hour trainer a diet free of
carbs and you really need to get down
the dead eyes stare that I learned from
Kate Moss oh you hear that I think
that's the ice cream man
don't you want ice cream Clinic actually
no I don't eat ice cream Barbara because
there's a bunch of soy gluten you know
and then other things and I just really
don't like to consume unless there's a
little bit of other things like goat's
milk is okay so join me next week when I
will be interviewing Michael Caine about
snapchat as you guys in there like pinks
and reds which is actually really good
for your veins it might make you seem
like oh don't worry I'll end it in down
your facing job